joe musgrove who is
ready to roll they take this series
there's joe musko with the out right
back where it came from one out
yelling moves up to the two spot
and yeah that strikes out that was sharp
yeah brandon woodruff an all-star a year
ago
there's a swing adam miss took a little
something off that
and frazier is strikeout victim number
one for woodrow
as he strikes out bell snap throw to
first just back
is evans almost a strikeout pick off
double play
logan morrison leads the way for the
brewers 3-2 pitch
swing and a miss good breaking ball and
musgrove has a couple of strikeouts he's
gone four up and four down
ryan reynolds leads off the bottom of
the second inning against woody
3-2 swinging to miss 97 mile an hour
fastball here's gregory polanco now
2-2 the count and he got him went to the
change-up and woodruff with back-to-back
case
he looks like he's on his game tonight
one two pitch
struck him out change up at 88
and he strikes out the side in the
second avi garcia will
start it for the brewers garcia rips one
down the right field line a fair ball
extra bases for abi syel garcia
a leadoff double on the first pitch of
the third good start to the inning by
milwaukee
put a good swing on it there it is two
seamer
kind of left it out over the plate and
garcia able to slice it down the line in
right good piece of hitting
1-0 on gamel ben gamel
sends that one way back oh my goodness
gamble launches one out of here a
two-run
home run for gamel just a no doubter
nicely done by ben gamble his first
homer
and that ball just launched out of here
a changeup bed he weighed it back on it
knocked it out of here and the brewers
do indeed score first
musgrove looks to second the pitch hit
hard
into left field a bay's hit reynolds up
with it runner waved home
here comes the throw to the plate it's
strong again and reynolds has done it
again
this time he combines with stallings
and reynolds gets another man you don't
run on brian reynolds
reynolds for the second straight night
throws a peg to the plate
and he's gunned down another brewers
runner
i didn't even get the swing off with two
strikes
didn't need any fielders this here's
that two seamer that you were talking
about joe that starts off the inside
part of the plate comes back
the one-two pitch swing and a miss
struck him out one two three for
muskrobe
woodruff looks in control
oh he got him that change up a
dandy bell fooled badly on the pitch and
woodruff with his sixth
strikeout 0-2 pitch and a swing at a
miss he went up the ladder with a
fastball
seven strikeouts for brandon woodruff
russ grove has allowed three hit
four strikeouts five strikeouts and
three in a row for muskrobe
he just picked a part gamma four
straight strikeouts now
for muskrobe and he strikes out
yelich brandon back on the bout
broken bad pop up out in the grass in
left field
and yelich will make the play for out
number two
13 in a row for woodruff 2-2 and it's a
fastball
called strike three brandon woodruff
strikes out
number eight two-nothing as they bound
here against joe musgrove casting hero
in the air center field got some carry
dyson on the run
at the wall and it is gone another home
run
for kesten hera in pittsburgh and it's
been in the
sixth inning in each of the last two
games for casting hero
fastball at 93 and he just sent it out
to center field pirates have been able
to get the ball out of the infield
once against him the only hit he gave up
was a swinging bunt to
philip evans in the first inning there's
a slider and a swing
and a miss and 16 in a row for woodruff
complete domination so far tonight 76
pitches
and he is in control of this baseball
game
he's faced 19 batters overall and
retired 18 of them ready for a 2-2
and bell chased one a fastball down
and bell strikes out woodruff will exit
after six
and a third so excellent day for brandon
woodruff just
one hit and one walk had a career-high
17 in a row retired
bottom of the ninth inning in pittsburgh
and josh hader is on to try and close it
out for the brewers
fouled it did he miss it or was it a
foul ball narvaez is saying foul
ball now the hands go up for calling him
out he's going to go down and in
oh yep it does hit him in the leg and
that's going to be a swing and a miss
strike three
2-2 picks popped him up this should do
it who wants it
sogard will make the call and the catch
and the ball game is over
an absolute pitching gem tonight for the
milwaukee brewers